[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everybody - to all mothers
in the audience happy Mother's Day and
of course most importantly today welcome
to the NBA recognition ceremony for 750
- special people right here class of
2018 let me be the first person to
welcome you and give us give you special
congratulations give yourselves a round
of applause collectively your class is
extraordinary and it's extraordinarily
diverse you come from 57 different
countries as far as Chile Sudan South
Korea Kazakhstan and the Netherlands and
you speak 33 different languages and
dialects including Portuguese Tagalog
Japanese Hebrew Hindi and I am told
English you come from countless
industries and professional backgrounds
and among you yessir consultants in
financiers but also singers bloggers
dancers cooks world travelers and
entrepreneurs of every stripe I hope and
we all hope that you take pride in all
that you have accomplished in fact three
of you have done exceptionally well
academically during your time at the
school and are graduating with a grade
point average of 10.0 or higher
graduations for you
no today this morning you join a vibrant
community of alumni who are decision
makers and leaders at the center of
business entrepreneurs industry pioneers
and game changers in fact 45,000 men and
women all over the world who do
influential and important work now
you've been working toward that role
since the day you got here and we've all
have been challenging you to be active
and engaged members of the community for
those in the audience let me assure you
that these folks have more than met this
challenge as students on campus whether
it's by serving your classmates through
formal channels like the peer advisor
program student government playing a
role in successful Colombia forever or
women's week or lending an invaluable
voice at club meetings and events or
simply sharing your ideas today this
morning is the occasion we sat aside so
that we as faculty and administration at
the school together with your family and
friends can celebrate your enormous
accomplishments and wish you success I
know that you leave this school well
equipped as leaders thinkers ready to
have an impact and I look forward to
seeing the change you will affect in the
lives that you lead and in your
communities but I want you to take a
moment with me an offer applause for
those who have supported you in your
time here everybody who's been with you
in the classroom and especially your
families
individually you have been exposed the
thought leadership that is informed by a
real-time global business environments
research from the faculty shows up in
the classroom and the curriculum and
access to leaders in New York City
really are unrivaled and you have access
to internships and the best firms in
finance or social enterprise retail to
name a few the reputation the strength
of this place has equipped you with the
knowledge and access that you need to
make a lasting impact is an alum it will
now provide you connections to support
and foster creativity invite your
entrepreneurial thinking and open doors
to opportunity these are tools that can
help strengthen your confidence and your
ability to succeed on your own terms but
I have to say to you this morning that
with the rewards of your MBA also come
responsibility what does it really mean
to be a graduate of Columbia Business
School we hope and expect that you
recall that we are and have always been
in the business of value but also the
business of values yes we are proud to
be the birthplace of value investing we
strive to add value in all disciplines
but we also recognize and need you to
recognize that personal values matter in
the workplace as you rise in your career
remember your courses in leadership in
an ethics which I hope inspire you to
pay forward and give back to new
generations of students I hope you
recognize your role as proud stewards of
Columbia Business School fortunately you
have many extraordinary examples to
follow in fellow alumni alumni like
Donnell Baird class of 2013
Darnell's tackling two problems he
witnessed growing up in Bedford
Stuyvesant in Brooklyn chronic
unemployment and high energy costs his
company blocked power trains
unconventional employees to install
energy of
technology for small businesses for
not-for-profits and underserved
communities
slashing energy costs and carbon dioxide
he's been recognized both as a business
person value but for his social
contributions values another example can
be found in sha Zhi Vista room class of
2004 sha Zhi founded happy family which
is the leading premium organic baby and
toddler food brand in the country in
2011 happy family debuted as number two
among food and beverage companies the
same year she was named one of the ten
top female entrepreneurs in the country
she wants the idea why she was in
business school and saw a big stake in
it to Danone in 2013 meanwhile when John
Stein 2009 was a novice investor he
thought he could do better than what
economics professors had drilled into
him by the way that's always a mistake
to think that the lesson that he was
trying to avoid was that the market
portfolio was the right one to own after
his first stock pick which happened to
be Enron failed and after deciding to
heed economists advice wise he created
betterment an online investment advisor
which offers consumers a better more
convenient way to invest in the market
portfolio today over 200 that the two
hundred and seventy thousand customers
invests more than ten billion dollars
with betterment you might also think of
Gerry spire Li Cooperman Henry Kravis
Roberts Smith Russ Carson Warren Buffett
Mario gabelli Jamie Curran Lima John
Martin Tim Campos or any of 45,000
movers and shakers that community that
network is an asset it belongs to you
you should leverage it for a lifetime so
what happens this morning exactly well
in one sense perhaps the familiar sense
you will graduate you will become part
of the alumni network throughout the
world you go from being a student to
being an alum continuing to make
her mark in the world like Teresa saputo
errand and Luis parks will be presented
this Wednesday with the Alumni medal of
service to Colombia it's precisely with
these thoughts in mind that we all
celebrate your graduation from a great
business school today it's a world-class
education I'm proud to have worked with
many of you in the classroom and I'm
particularly proud to be your Dean but
while it's easy to be reflective on a
day like this I prefer the more
old-fashioned term than graduation I
prefer the term commencement because it
has a specific reference to both
beginnings and transitions you begin
soon a renewed life of engagement in
business and in society you have much to
contribute to both and I know and we all
know that you will but most of all if
there's one thing to remember today I
want you to never forget what a noble
calling business is and the power that
lies within each and every one of you to
transform the lives of other business
leaders and entrepreneurs your fellow
alumni communities and nations around
the world
remember your MBA is a master of choices
what matters most to me matters most of
all of us is not the change that's
jingling in your pockets after
commencement but the change you will
make in the world congratulations again
give yourselves another round of
applause
it is now my pleasure to give a Columbia
Business School welcome to our
distinguished speaker Senator Ron Wyden
the very first thing that MBA students
experience at Columbia is a course on
leadership and personal values as I
noted earlier we take values seriously
because we take leadership seriously
which is why senator Wyden is such a
fitting speaker today he has spent his
career creating value by finding common
ground across the political spectrum I
don't think that's terribly easy today
senator I thank you for that he pushes
innovative policies that protect our
seniors children and fellow Americans
those represent values that he holds
dear and values the nation holds dear
through principled bipartisanship
he's also introduced comprehensive tax
reform improvements to Medicare health
care reform legislation and improvements
to security infrastructure and
surveillance laws he's championed
solutions that allow parties to stay
true to their values and beliefs while
bringing out agreements that bring value
to the nation he was first elected to
Congress in 1980 to represent Oregon's
3rd congressional district he was
elected to the United States Senate in
1996 and is currently the ranking member
of the Senate Finance Committee and a
member of the Senate Select Committee on
Intelligence ultimately we want all of
our graduates to be outstanding leaders
like Senator Wyden in fact his daughter
Lily is poised to be such a leader as
she graduates with you today it's my
pleasure my pleasure and honor to have
him here please help me welcome senator
Wyden
Dean thank you very much for that
unquestionably inflationary introduction
and graduates lily reminded me this
morning that you like your speeches
short and your celebrations long so I am
pleased to say at this early hour I now
declare this program to be a filibuster
free zone I knew that'd go over well
graduates and family members and friends
we all congratulate you today I know
there is great pride for what you've
accomplished and by the way who you have
surrounded yourself with the Dean
mentioned that there are 57 countries in
the house this morning that's a big
fraction of the United Nations there are
rows and rows of students whose
upbringing and cultures are very
different and you are united by a shared
appreciation that one does not get a
Columbia MBA by osmosis the sweat equity
that was built up over literally
thousands of hours of hard work and
sacrifice from you and your families is
what made this day possible
and that is why all of us parents and
friends are calling that is Yiddish for
gushing over all of you today now I'm
going to start my brief remarks with a
bit of wisdom from the late great
comedian Jack Benny for those
unfamiliar with Benny he was the Jimmy
Falon of the Mesozoic era one afternoon
Benny was confronted on a walk by an
armed robber the robber pointed a gun at
him the robber shouted your money or
your life
Benny rubbed his chin kind of like this
and goes I'm thinking I'm thinking this
infuriated the robber the robber goes
what are you doing what are you doing
it's your choice
and Benny said cuz he was notoriously
cheap I'm trying to decide man trying to
decide the robber is now
hyperventilating it's never seen anybody
like Benny throws up his hands and runs
off this is not being told to you to
tout the virtues of procrastination and
it is not a metaphor for the world
sticking a figurative gun in your face
the point however is graduates you do
not have to choose between the life that
you want to live and financial security
now with respect to life you know life
isn't gonna be a cakewalk after you take
off your robes and it feels today like
there are two kinds of people those who
read the news and those who sleep well
at night and recently you graduates got
a snapshot of the life that awaits you
after this ceremony I saw the notice
that went around the campus right before
spring break warning you to be careful
about where you would travel over your
holiday not hard graduates to get the
drift about that it was clear that
depending on where and how you travel
there was no guarantee that despite all
of your hard work you might not be able
to get back in the country and be here
to pick up your degree that is graduates
only one ominous example of the
extremism creeping into our lives today
it has been joined by regular attacks on
free speech attacks on Free Press
attacks on free elections in this
country around the world autocrats
and dictators have significantly limited
the freedom of travel and more now we
have been challenged here before not too
long ago well-meaning and hardworking
Americans faced down fascism I know a
little bit about it because it was part
of my family's heritage decades ago my
Jewish father and his family fled the
Nazis in Germany not all of them got out
my father had been kicked out of school
for being unwilling to give the Nazi
salute he wasn't all that unhappy though
because it meant he was no longer being
beaten up for this small act
of defiance upon arriving in America my
dad taught himself English at eleven a
few years later he wanted to take the
fight to the Nazis on behalf of his new
country but it would be fair to say he
was not exactly the most impressive
physical specimen around but boy did he
want to take it to the Nazis so he
convinced the army brass that he could
write the propaganda pamphlets that we
would drop on the Nazis from the air
those pamphlets they did the trick they
fell over the Nazi frontlines in the
dead of winter
Hitler according to my dad's words was
gonna let all those troops freeze to
death
they'd be frozen in a matter of weeks I
still have those pamphlets and they
smoked years later in part because of
those pamphlets from my dad and others
many Germans decided to pack it in
believing Hitler couldn't care less if
they lived until spring now that was a
different era huge armies spread across
the continents putting an existential
threat in front of entire nations but
make no mistake about it graduates
freedoms are under attack today and
fortunately every Columbia MBA has many
more tools to protect freedom than my
dad did with his little pamphlets so
I've got a request for each of you today
and that is to take the skills that you
have sharpened on this campus and
throughout your
lives work in opposition to the
autocrats that scheme to reduce
individual freedoms around the world
that could be something as simple as
voting every election
it could mean building an inclusive
positive workplace that treats women and
people of color in LGBTQ individuals
with the same basic decency everybody
deserves it could mean running for
office someday yourselves
bottom line I believe you will be amazed
at the difference your ingenuity can
make when it comes to defending human
rights and dignity for all now have
thought about the financial aspects of
your days ahead
my take here is this is an extraordinary
time to channel your inner Ben Franklin
Ben Franklin was the originator of the
theory do well by doing good he proved
that making money and making a
difference those two are not mutually
exclusive for example right now
improving healthcare when so many are
falling between the cracks and suffering
or reducing carbon emissions are just
two urgencies that come to mind
and by the way Columbia MBAs have a leg
up on this doing well by doing good
because I know there have been courses
here offered on socially responsible
entrepreneurship little example there's
a US company called zip line that has
been working with the Rwandan government
to use drone
to deliver life-saving packets of blood
to children in remote villages the
company is now pushing to take the
essentials of modern medicine around the
world this month the Federal Aviation
Administration is looking at how
companies like zipline can deliver such
products to rural Americans and you
don't have to look very far from our
shores to do well with respect to health
care by doing good last year Americans
spent about three point five trillion
dollars on health care now lily has
reminded me of your very sophisticated
math skills so divide 320 million into
three point five trillion I see a couple
people with calculators and wonder if
senators can count and you could send
every family of four in America a check
for almost $40,000 and say here go buy
some health care so we're spending a lot
of money we're not spending it until a
very well and until recently the
government the federal government had
policies with respect to Medicare the
largest federal program that actually
served the hamstring entrepreneurs from
being able to use their skills and their
capacity to innovate and come up with
new ideas here's what I'm talking about
until recently Medicare was basically an
acute care program that meant if you
broke your ankle you went to the
hospital folks that in Medicare anymore
Medicare today is about cancer it's
about diabetes it's about heart disease
it's about chronic pulmonary disease it
is a chronic care program and guess what
both the Democrats and the Republicans
missed it with all the fighting missed
it but I can stand before you today and
tell you that the chairman of the
Finance Committee Orrin Hatch he treats
me like his son my older daughter said
the other day she said dads are twenty
five senators older than you she said
you're in the only profession on earth
where somebody your age is considered
young and when I brought to him this
idea of a chronic care bill he said
absolutely and so now more older people
are gonna get health care services where
they want it at home less expensive than
institutional care we're going to see
telemedicine play a bigger role by the
way outside the home
this is gonna be hugely important
because if you're in a small town
anywhere anywhere and a patient has had
a stroke and there's not a neurologist
nearby telemedicine is what gives you
access to the best advice around the
world so that's what's going to change
and I just wanted to highlight
particularly areas where I know that you
all are going to be able to make an
enormous difference for the well-being
of people here and around the world one
final thought as you all leave here
today working to promote freedom and
doing well by doing good
one little bit of unsolicited advice I
believe you will never regret not taking
a bolder leap life is just one run
around the block and sprint through as
much of it as you can
so I mentioned that we parents are doing
some serious Covelli today and it seems
like yesterday when Lily who were so
proud of today was just four years old
and I tucked her into bed one night and
her tiny chin was barely visible above
the covers she looked at me and she
smiled and said ah nice peace quiet
graduates wherever your lives may take
you I wish you many happy moments like
that Godspeed and congratulations
thank you very much senator for those
thoughtful words it is now my pleasure
to welcome our student speaker this
morning Josh will land it
now josh josh has quite literally been
playing the part of a leader since
earning his master's degree in acting
from the national theater conservatory
at Denver's Center for the Performing
Arts after earning his bachelor's degree
from Brown he knew he wanted to pursue
his ultimate passion of theater and has
been gracing the stages ever since from
Broadway to London to Las Vegas and
importantly for us today he's also a
leader off the stage serving as an arts
educator with the new victory theater
developing curriculum and workshops for
public school students throughout New
York Josh has been a highly engaged
member of the Columbia Business School
community he served as chair of cluster
Y VP of East Coast visits for the media
Management Association and VP of
Performing Arts for the Arts Society
after graduation he'll be joining
Rosie's theatre kids an arts education
organization as the general manager his
most important role today join me in
welcoming Josh
Thank You Dean Hubbard for your kind and
generous introduction and thank you
senator wyden for joining us today I
would also like to thank you of my
classmates and the Office of Student
Affairs for giving me the chance to
share my thoughts with all of you thank
you to our esteemed faculty and staff
for giving us such an incredible
experience during our time here at
Columbia Business School and thank you
to all of our friends and family members
for standing by our side and for being
here with us this morning thank you
thank you to my wife Ashley who inspires
me every single day to my dad and my
father-in-law for all of your support
and to my mom my mother-in-law my
sisters and all of the other moms and
extraordinary women in our lives
happy Mother's Day we love you day one
as you walk in the door you're handed a
few costume pieces a hat
a pair of glasses a necklace you're
nervous but as you look around the room
you get the sense that everybody's
nervous so you sit down at the table
your name is displayed right in front of
you and you place your pen at the ready
here we go we all know this scene but I
never imagined that life in Business
School would be so much like life in the
theater
I mean who thought that we would have
dance rehearsals that first week right
we did but that first day of orientation
was remarkably similar to a first
read-through of a play with the key
difference being that at CBS each of us
was seeking to define our role as
opposed to having it handed to us and
the play
hadn't been written yet we would do that
together
constructing our collective story
unified in purpose and today this moment
is our opening performance everything
leading up to it has been preparation
we've already seen remarkable feats from
this class among them students who
brought water filtration products to
Mexico another student who in the midst
of his MBA ran for political office
another classmate who just a couple
weeks ago opened her own hip new caf
our classmates are launching startups
that are bound to shake things up a new
marketplace for pet insurance an app for
incentivized recycling a networking
platform for new teachers but none of
these students not a single one of us
can achieve what we've set out to on our
own we rely on each other every day and
when any one of us reaches the spotlight
the rest of us don't just sit and watch
we stand by our classmates supporting
them every step of the way but it's not
just our accomplishments and our
collaboration that makes CBS special
this institution is unique because of
who we are this community has brought
together a young man from Sudan and a
young woman from Cleveland to serve as
co-presidents of our class
this is a community in which a guy who
self-identifies as a Muslim feminist
from Pakistan and a Bronze Star
Afghanistan veteran specifically chose
to share their CBS matters presentation
I treasure my own experience of
embarking on a student-led chastened
tour to Guatemala where we met leaders
from large multinational corporations
and small nonprofit organizations and in
doing so we learned that both industry
and philanthropy must play a pivotal
role in transforming the lives of people
in poverty but beyond that we had the
chance to see Guatemala our classmates
home country through her eyes at CBS we
have been given a gift to learn so much
from each other and in doing so to learn
so much about the world but we still
have work to do you know at every CBS
matters presentation where a student
chooses to share what really matters to
him or her I find myself thinking huh I
never knew that and I think we've all
experienced this feeling this moment
when you realize that you never knew
that someone went through such hardship
or you never realized that your
classmate was so passionate about art or
science or even math
you never had insight into what it was
like to grow up in China or Argentina or
Kazakhstan or Italy and there's a great
lesson to be learned in this moment of
discovery and that's the fact that for
all of us
there's always something underneath
there's always something unexpected to
be learned
we may be conditioned to make snap
judgments about other people but if we
can continue to strengthen our ability
to empathize to give each other a chance
it won't only help us to do well by
doing good
it will also empower us to be true
global leaders so I have to confess that
I got more than a few requests for the
circle of life the lion sleeps tonight
CBS Football Club I'm looking at you
guys and Hakuna Matata what a wonderful
phrase and and while I'm not gonna use
this time to sing there is a lesson to
be learned from the Lion King
so for those of you who might not know
this story Simba the future king runs
away from home when things get tough
he's scared and he doesn't know what to
do but with the help of some unlikely
friends he meets in the jungle he's
reminded of his responsibility his duty
and and with the help of those friends
he regains his confidence to come back
home and fulfill his destiny throughout
our lives throughout our careers things
will get tough but don't ever don't ever
give up on your purpose
whatever you do our lead professor Madhu
pea canola always said you were created
because there is some problem out there
that you are uniquely equipped to solve
we should all remember that
and when times
tough we should trust that our
classmates are there after all we don't
just sit in the wings and watch we stand
by our classmates and support each other
of every step of the way we look deeper
to better understand who people really
are underneath the silly hat the glasses
the necklace or whatever other costume a
person might wear each day and we stay
true to our mission as each of us
strives to truly define our role today
is only the beginning let's seize this
opportunity to reflect on what we've
accomplished to celebrate our
achievements and to stand shoulder to
shoulder as the curtain rises the world
can't wait to see what we've got in
store for them thank you and
congratulations to the Columbia Business
School class of 2018
thank you so much Josh for the words of
inspiration good morning everyone
well good morning most everyone I
understand there may be a few people in
blue for whom good evening might be more
appropriate at this point I'm pleased to
present two awards this morning the
Singhvi prize and the lira award these
two awards reflect the values of
inclusion and recognition within the
Columbia Business School community the
first award is the Tsing V prize for
scholarship in the classroom the
recipient is selected by the graduating
students and awarded to a full-time
faculty member who exemplifies
excellence in the classroom based on his
or her dedication to teaching and
ability to communicate knowledge and
encourage students our winner this year
teaches the core MBA and EMBA strategy
course and an elective and Technology
Strategy he earned his BA from Columbia
University and his PhD from Stanford
students consistently say that they are
thrilled to experience his liveliness
engagement and overall terrific
classroom environment this year he was
named two poets and quants list of the
best 40 Business School professors under
the age of 40 while he is unable to join
us in person because he is leading a
student trip to Elon bot or Mongolia
this week please join me in
congratulating the 2018 winner of the
Tsing V prize for scholarship in the
classroom professor Dan Wang
our next award the Robert W leer award
the leer award is presented to a faculty
or administrator for service to the
students above and beyond the call of
duty this year's recipient is a proud
first-generation college graduate from
the College of Mount Saint Vincent who
went on to earn his master's degree from
Stony Brook University he's known for
his relentless enthusiasm and humor in
working with our student government
clubs and the peer advising program he
builds a sense of belonging by making
each student he works with feel included
engaged and valued please join me in
congratulating the 2018 winner of the
Robert W leer award Scott a seagull
Ortiz
[Applause]
for the presentation of our community
and service awards I have the pleasure
to introduce to you our Dean of Students
deanzie salon Crawford oh I know you
could do better than that
[Applause]
before I start with our Awards I just
wanted to say to all of you I'm so proud
of you we will always be family and CBS
will always be your home so protect your
house and don't do anything to
compromise your own personal integrity
or the integrity of the brand let's
start I'm pleased to continue the awards
presentation by recognizing the
recipients of the community and service
awards the New York Alumni Club award is
given to a student in the top 10% of
their class on the basis of exceptional
academic achievement outstanding
character participation in school
affairs and potential for civic business
and professional leadership this year's
New York Alumni Award recipient is Jenny
ray LaRue
the Heffernan award for service given to
graduating students who serve the school
behind the scenes and contributed to the
academic standards operations spirit and
integrity of the business school
community these awards are selected by
the administration the Business School
student services award honoring students
who have made contributions to the
business school community are selected
by all of you the graduating class the
Heffernan award for service is presented
to Victoria Dinh Griffin dowdy Imani
good'n
[Applause]
Connor Leary
andrew kikuchiyo
Emily Schneider
Jefferson Taylor
[Applause]
Benjamin sube Anna
jam to Kelly
and Matt Wilson
nomads recipients for both the Heffernan
award for service and the business
school service award are Anna auginaush
and Molly Magnuson
recipients for the business school
service award are Katie cook Gregory
Feldman Gabriel gobble Gonzalez
TJ ha the son who's named Enrique parada
Sarah Shanker
Allen grands burg
who was also selected by the first year
class for outstanding teaching assistant
award which is given to and recognition
to a student who provided outstanding
skill care and involvement in pretending
and pretending
[Applause]
in presenting class material Helen
Greensburg
[Music]
last but not least Brunel mahanta who
was also who was also presented the
Suresh Bala Raman prize this prize is
presented annually to graduating
students who have demonstrated
outstanding work in the field of finance
this is presented by Professor Charles
Jones for the remaining academic Awards
I'm pleased to welcome back Dee Malone
to the podium thanks Allen we are
pleased now to acknowledge Columbia
Business School's academic awards
recipients for the class of 2018
students are selected by the faculty and
our faculty representatives will present
recipients with their awards this
morning first presented by Professor
Elizabeth Webb our two awards the Shuman
Hobart award in marketing which
recognizes a graduating student with an
outstanding record in the study of
marketing who shows promise of future
contributions to the field and the Amana
Elliott Webster Memorial Award in
marketing given to a graduating woman
who has shown overall academic
excellence in the area of marketing
this year's recipient for both Awards is
Farina Ahmed
[Applause]
next presented by Professor Charles
Jones is the Robert and Jacqueline
Whillans
tax research project award this award
it's a thing this award recognizes
superior performance in the area of tax
theory and practice or research and this
year's recipient is will meow
our next award presented by Professor
aru's Khan is the Robert W the Robert H
Montgomery is the Robert H Montgomery
prize in accounting
the Montgomery prize is awarded for
excellence in the area of accounting and
this year's recipient is James sour beer
professor Medina Singh will present our
next award
[Applause]
this award this award is the award for
academic excellence in decision risk and
operations which is presented annually
to a graduating student who demonstrates
outstanding performance in the field
this year's recipient is Jacob Alcorn
[Applause]
the next two prizes will be presented by
Professor Charles Jones first the Ellie
Ginsburg memorial prize is presented
annually to a graduating students who
has done outstanding work in the field
of economics or human resources this
year's recipient is Jonathan Dwyer
a change in program
our next award will be presented by
Professor Bruce Kogut the Nathan gantter
prize for social enterprise which is
presented annually to the graduating
student who best demonstrates dedication
to the public and not-for-profit sector
and who exemplifies inner strength and
personal integrity special consideration
is given if that student can sing the
lion sleeps tonight
therefore this year's recipient is Josh
landing
our final academic award is presented by
Professor Todd Jack the award for
academic excellence in management is
presented annually to a graduating
students who demonstrates outstanding
performance in the field this year's
recipient is Cheri Lee
[Applause]
lastly we'd like to recognize this
year's recipient for the Campbell Award
the Campbell Award is this morning
presented by Peter Valerius from the
class of 2015 who is a member of the
Columbia Alumni Association Board the
University Trustees and board of the
Columbia Alumni Association established
the Campbell award and it's given to one
graduating student from each school at
the University who shows exceptional
leadership and Columbia Spirit as
exemplified by the late Bill Campbell
chair emeritus University trustee
outstanding alumnus and CAA co-founder
please join me in congratulating the
2018 recipient of the Campbell Award
Sonja Nanda
I now have the distinct pleasure to
introduce you this morning to our
student government co-president Hashim
Ibrahim
[Applause]
good morning first I would like to start
by saying thank you senator wyden god
bless you and god bless people like your
dad I was really moved by his story
Dean Hubbard Dean Malone Dean Crawford
our distinguished guest speaker senator
wyden distinguished faculty and
administration family friends and
absolutely the amazing class of 2018 I'm
incredibly honored and humbled to be
standing here in front of you today is a
special day it's Mother's Day
happy Mother's Day to all mothers if
your mother is here today you are really
lucky I would like to send a special one
to my mom I love you mom and I know you
are watching now I would like to start
by coating meal and kundra the French
rider the chick born French rider he
said chance and chance alone has a
message for us everything that occurs
out of necessity
everything expected repeated day in and
day out is mute only chance can speak to
us we are so lucky to be here now the
reality is this moment is one of those
few moments in our lives when love luck
and hard work come together to create
something beautiful how many of you
remember that call when you hit that you
got admitted to Columbia Business School
I remember mine I was in a taxi I weed
no caller ID showed on my phone I picked
up and I heared Hashem
this is Amanda Carlson from Columbia
Business School all what I remembered
after this I was screaming in that taxi
and the driver looked at me and said you
better give me a big tip just as many of
you I can't I came to Columbia Business
School with big dreams I came after a
long journey a journey of hope and
belief my journey started where I grew
up in Sudan a country unfortunately they
were stated by the longest civil war in
Africa and now for more than 28 years
ruled by a dictator and under a warrant
from the International Criminal Court my
father was a political journalist during
this very oppressive regime some nights
he wasn't at home and my mother would
tell me that he was in prison again
because again he chose to take stands
with his words not every country
respects a person freedom of speech
god Bless America so my father was
banned from journalism we soon solved
everything we had it was a difficult
experience for our family and after 15
years of staying at home taking care of
me and my five siblings my mom decided
to go back to work in my father's
darkest hours my mom stood by him and
made it possible for us to have a home
that's the power of family and today as
we are surrounded by your natural family
and the family built at Columbia
Business School we get to pay to say
thanks together like each one of you I
am here only because of the sacrifices
and selflessness of men so many people
believed in me everyone can say how much
it how hard you should work and push
through how much focus you should put
and how many all-nighters it takes to
achieve ambitious goals but the reality
is all of this is not enough
all of this can help you knock the door
we need people who are on the other side
to reach out and open those doors for us
I wouldn't be standing here if it's not
for the sacrifices of my family I
wouldn't be standing here without that
testing center manager who took a chance
on me and allow me to sit for the GMAT
even though my country is under
sanctions I wouldn't be standing here
without Melina and her team who
supported me and facilitated an
institutional loan to complete my
education because all banks refused to
give me loans because of my nationality
I wouldn't be standing here without my
friends who supported me throughout my
time at Columbia Business School I want
you all to take a moment and think about
all the people who supported us through
those special two years that friend who
helped you through the core homeworks
and final that friend who called you
when you are feeling down to take you
out that friend who made sure you got
home safe after an open bar after party
that friend who moved you out after a
breakup or a new relationship that
friend who stood by you when you recruit
you were recruiting and getting all
those beautiful rejection calls and that
friend who celebrated you even before
your super day those are some of the
people who made it possible for us to be
here now we got lucky
they opened doors for us when we knocked
and now it's our turn to open for others
today we celebrate our graduation
together your next personal milestone
may be your marriage or a baby or
perhaps your first median I hope so let
us commit to celebrating some of those
moments also together let us commit to
staying in touch
not only on Facebook I hope to see you
all at our five-year reunion at
Manhattan's Ville
it's it's happening it's happening
we came to Columbia Business School with
big dreams and now we are leaving not
only with big dreams but also is a
bigger family I love you all
how have an incredible fulfilling life
ahead congratulations on this moment
class of 2018
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so much
allow me to introduce someone who needs
no introduction her contribution to our
community is beyond measure and I'm so
grateful to call her a great friend and
a fellow co-president join me to welcome
Molly Magnuson to the body
[Applause]
it's really hard to follow a
professional actor and someone with such
heart and charisma as Hashem but all
I'll do my best
it was a struggle to come up with
something to say today and I mean that
literally I found myself with a broken
phone that contained the only version of
my speech don't ask me how
during our unofficial graduation trip to
Puerto Rico this past week and not
having access to your phone gives one
time to think maybe too much time a real
stripping away of the inessential
and that got me thinking how scary yet
rejuvenating a fresh start or a clean
slate can be a difficult and daunting
task made bearable by the number of
memories and experiences here at CBS
that I'm taking forward with me we all
had very different goals coming in mine
was mediocrity and I say that with total
comfort and no shame for being
middle-of-the-road with all of you fine
people looked pretty darn good to me but
we're all leaving with the same thing a
degree a two-year experience that no one
can take away from us
I felt that while here it was pretty
clear what one had to do to physically
graduate although I did overhear some
panicked conversations in Puerto Rico
and confusion around what number of
credits you actually needed it was 60 by
the way
and we knew what we had to do to get in
and to graduate here today but what was
the next step and obviously that meant a
job but you know are we taking the right
job and meant a lot of different things
to all of us friends have told me along
the way that my 20s would be filled with
asking this question along with the
freedom to mess up and try again or take
a different path then I gently remind
them that I'm in my 30s and I wonder if
the same rules apply and it gets really
silent and I digress in high school I
read Moby Dick and one chapter in
particular has stuck with me all these
years
chapter xlvii the mapmaker it talks
about fate and free will and chance and
we can't do much about fate but we can
acknowledge chance and embrace free will
and it comes down to how you play those
two all of us sitting here today may not
be entirely arbitrary it was certainly a
lot of hard work and grit but we must
sense its arbitrary aspect as Hostin
Hashem said we are a lucky few we're
lucky in our existence our parents our
teachers our mentors we're lucky that we
got to be put together with a bunch of
other lucky people so let's not try to
forget how lucky we are but also the
obligation that comes with that the
scary yet truly exciting thing about our
next step in our lives and ahead of CBS
is that there is no core curriculum
praise be
the entire place is an elective and
abundance of free will the paths are
infinite the outcomes uncertain and it
likely will be maddening to us because
our strength has always been about
achievement an MBA is something you
complete which I think most of us have
and life is something we experience and
maybe we like achievement so much
because it is a marker of success that
we can control experiences entail good
and bad highs and lows and sometimes
very little control I was fortunate
enough to have a dear friend and while
she's no longer with us
she taught me something about the joy of
living but most significantly
she taught me life perspective to find
comedy signs of a greater life plan or
meaning in some of the most trivial or
frustrating situations and for me that's
really been a lifesaver because things
will go wrong in friendship and in
business and in love and in health and
in all the other ways that life can go
wrong and when things get tough what
else can we do but try our hand at doing
just that so what did I get from my
experience at CBS I for one conquer two
very real fears one was if you're a
flying and the other public speaking
thanks to all the trips in my log I
somehow managed to conquer the former
and if I've made it this far in my
speech then it means I've also somewhat
successfully conquered the latter but in
seriousness we want so desperately to
believe that our time and experiences
here mattered that they mean something
and it did to an extent but in
behavioral economics I learned that when
you look backwards
your memories are defined by two moments
the peak in the end we all experience
these different highs and lows but today
is our collective end and I'm so glad we
get to have this moment together because
I think it is in fact the people that we
meet along the way who shared in our
lives even if just for a small fleeting
moment I don't know if you think
two years is a long time we're really
short amount of time that make this
experience so important years ago my dad
described life to me as an intricate web
of people's gifts to one another dad you
might not remember telling me that but
you did I am thankful to so many of you
for friendship and community ones that
require no pretension or prerequisites
which I believe is really the ultimate
act of gift-giving as I'm sure many of
us feel today I'm grateful to CBS for
learning how to think differently to
navigate uncertainty learn by doing and
certainly influence without any
semblance of authority I am grateful to
everyone in admissions obviously I was
watching Lady Bird on the plane this
past week and a young girl receives the
letter notifying her that she got into
her dream school and perhaps it was the
music plane but I could not stop bawling
and I think the woman sitting next to me
thought I was having a breakdown and
mind you I haven't even broken my point
at this point it was on the way to
Puerto Rico but it was just all so
viscerally familiar I felt like I had
just gotten that call from Amanda
Carlson yesterday perhaps one of the
best moments of my life and I'm sure for
many of you it was the same I'm grateful
to have learned how to become
comfortable with being uncomfortable as
your class president I really wish I had
taken courses earlier in my experience I
think that having difficult
conversations module and simulation and
PLS and power and influence and top
management would have been helpful to
get through the year but lucky for me
I've had the good friendship and
guidance as many of you and the patients
from most all of you have commanded a
presence in my everyday through fate and
fortune adding depth and color and
relevance to my experience and for that
I am so grateful most of all I'm
thankful for the infinite memories with
all of you so intertwined with my own
and the numerable things you taught me
about fortitude character and
perseverance I know that I am lucky
humble to be graduating from Columbia a
place that understands and rewards the
bet that many of us are placing on
ourselves
and expensive that no let no less and I
hope I feel the same way in year 10 of
my loan repayments but you can ask me at
reunion thank you to the Executive Board
in student government my cluster mates
all the way in the back there yeah H
obviously a few in the front with the
award recipients all my fellow failures
for letting me just laugh and yeah that
all out professors and my mentor and
biggest cheerleader sharing the stage
with me today Dean Crawford and on
behalf of all my classmates because I
think I'll take the liberty and assume
all of you feel the same thank you to
our family and friends because without
you it would not have only been
impossible to have done this but it
would have been meaningless I am filled
with optimism about the potential for
this class to do things that matter and
I'm confident in everyone's abilities
sitting here to contribute all of you
truly know how to frame a problem with
you're hungry intellect and most of you
with an open mind and now it's just a
time it's just a matter of not being
afraid to use what you know and to share
what you've learned here I am getting
all preachy but I can't help it I know
that you'll embrace the future because
from what I've experienced we all thrive
on the notion that we can change it
congratulations class of 2018 I'm so
humbled to be just one of us such a
commanding and impressive crew keep it
real keep it honest and remember that
I'll always be cheering for you thank
you
[Applause]
congratulations before I start calling
names congratulations on not only
starting your own businesses or getting
your dream job or working with us to
drive change at CBS but I've seen
firsthand how you've rallied behind your
classmates when they needed you most
from supporting your classmates who are
impacted by hurricanes in Puerto Rico
Houston and floods in India to the
sudden loss of parents grandparents
brothers sisters nieces and nephews you
are all family now so on this special
day I know you'll be tempted to leave
but I want you to clap and cheer for
every single one of your classmates who
walk across the stage because they
deserve it
are you ready are you ready let's get it
cluster axe
Sara Ahmed aired in I'll say Christopher
Arzu manian Pat Bunyan Pia pod
Rajeev Batra Shefali bhardwaj Catalina
Rondo Alexander burns lina maria Bustos
bianca Caban Alejandra Camacho Ingram
carpenter lucifina
serrano Kate cha Justin Charles
Roxy Chen Jonathan a Cohen Jonathan
Cohen
Jeremy counter
ekaterina to meet you Ava Sylvia or Kenz
Timur s ryoga's Gustavo Gaspar Campania
Javier Gil out of fat Philip grant
Ross gibbard Dalton John
a thief Janine Michael kidding
Cristiano Cristiano Cheryl Lynn Marty
Lopez
Rosa Laura Lopez Linda Lou
Evangeline willow Carol mown Daniel
Martinez Fabian Muller Mateos Veneto Ben
Parr Bonnie
Lucas graziotti Stefan Sakai
Daniel Seagle Robin Shapiro Deborah ray
Rifkin Jennifer silverstein to bomb
single David sit
mariusz scrum doll Taylor Smith
Jack Stevens Audrey stickers min-soo
sung Jacqueline
Samaras Steve tool Lily widen road
youngnam zip on yang Jung mo u n-- see
we cluster why
eniola album bola
Robert Edelson
Lucas a years uh
Bonnie Pahari Gabriel Lucas parcel miss
Matt Bellamy
[Applause]
Christopher case burn
play canning
Emily carton Zeron Chen Sheldon Chang
[Applause]
mark shovel you Gormley sana Chopra
Teresa
Leonarda Chacho
Francesco Leonardo when Sony Maria Porto
Zeinab era blue
Sarah Ferrari Oh
George Franklin Cooley Gerlach
[Applause]
where's Barden Garant Lau Cheung z-coil
one Humbert Alan the Toyman Lindsay
Johnson Sean Kerr
Pavitra cub Coon salon omma coloretti
Assis Raj Kumar Murali Krishna
Samuel D 1 Quan Yin lei Brian Leon Wei
Lian er yeah
Malik deep master would eat Malini
el Toro mellow Nora mean a case that I
can say right sorry
Ricardo machete
Chirag noir track Patrick opiod Matthew
Rosen
Jonathan Rossi Erich Schaefer
Josh Shanker read shufflin Josh chin
Alice Signori so healing
since our jaw Adriana
Souza a Silva Sarah spear Bruna supply
see Andrew Tom
Daniel Tedesco
karl-oskar tone Eureka chuckles ooh me
Diego oh yeah
Bundy Chi
Felipe mandolins Jeremy yang Karl Ziad
cluster Z will Albertus Patrick bellman
[Applause]
Lukasz Paulo Diego cosas con cada Julio
Cheon
Siobhan Chopra George doable to veena a
sulfur aji David Faulkner Corey Fulton
Arielle gold
Michael Hardiman Matt Henderson Rodrigo
Husni Tate Jackson Jeffrey Kowski Deepti
camka
Jun Hyun Kim Jun will Kim Thomas cloaca
Nos
Natalie Fung Scott David Krisha
Victoria Kwai JWoww Yan Julie
Santiago Mascheroni Marwan Mattar
Daniel McConnell am on mate I'm Lindsay
barley Mehran contra Wang Jin de daniel
nedelin Alvaro Nunez Gonzalez
7ch Altay
[Applause]
andres palacios chipper
Gonzalo Plotnik samhita rahaga Philip
Wolfgang Renner Elena return mo Chou
Chou Bernard iam romo whoosh I'm sorry
Walla Francesca
charreah Joseph urban Michael Shoob
Tanya Silva Tucker hero
so be choko Tanaka Christian tansy
Chad tap and Dorff Miguel
Taveras Nicholas tropen
next van Bruggen Kyra fling a lawn
vebber Dara Wiese Paola Wallner fella
pack
Anthony Yakubu Alima Zima Nova cluster a
Matthew Albert Renata Almeida in some
fake Paul Barsky
James Simon Beale Jessica vital men
Hudson bova
Nicholas nubby 3ot Brian cherry Joseph
Bernard Cosentino Spencer duhain
Benjamin Eisler Manuel Fernandez Jurado
nemecio Fernandez cuesta Stephie fitter
Elliott fry ja Furtado Oliver garsten
Geoffrey George ISA bail he'll casseras
Monica Gorman sander Gossard Donovan
Hamlet the trend Hyun
Natasha Adnani I Ming G Natasha Mohan
Corgan car Daniel
LeBlanc
Bayon Leigh Allen Leigh Isabella Lin
Tristan Lafleur Jorge Luis Perez Ethan
Mack a wait
Ethan James Makai sorry woo Bravo
mastani Matthew man
Federico Martino Liz Nylund Nisa Ostra
Alison Peron Ambler Roman freedom
Isabel Rosenthal Alexandra Elizabeth
Savona Chirag Shah
Ricky Shen Feld Wei Qing she shahru
single brunette ethos of Rio brain
dhenuka Silva
Claire Tang Michael Torsen me Nino
tahadia Kirsten Turnbull Aaron Lynn V
Hill
Evelyn fun bishops often Annie Wang
Dylan West Mallory West
[Music]
Anika Williams
Stephanie 'seeing pan Fei yen taya sow
cluster beam avi Shalom are done
Junie Astor Rowland Kelly comme la opti
ace Junior
Guillermo August Aaron Colleen Bobby och
yup Rock fun run baron play Bartlet
Samuel Benson Theresa burgle San Martin
Benjamin Bergsma Dianna Berkovitz Kathy
Chang martica wanker
Ruiz Karen Tommy
Samuel Fenwick Axl Freitag Chama he
kofuku sue me
Annabel Elizabeth Grassley flower
Mariano Mariano Gomez Quiroga John
Grogan kou Zhu Jie tile ha Masahiro sob
young woo young Jason Kiev itch it Marwa
Khan Lina quo Joseph Lee Alexandra
Layton Ashley
Lee Benjamin Lincoln Kelly Lipson
Heather Fong Lu
Thiago Mafra Alexander Smith Berg
Margolis
Andrew marques Michael Martin oh it's
Mario Mario and moneena Dorothea McGrath
Edwin McLaughlin Mehmet red sheet Melek
Alison Minogue
Oliver not rare April Qi Alice
rah George Rock Steven Rosenthal
Christopher Russell Nicole savour e nas
Shawn's Sudeep doe shown call a Siddiqui
Sun King so Aaron Jacob spring got
Alexander Teixeira Andrew Valerie Angela
Wang Stacy Mullane Warren Joanne
Williams
TJ Winfrey Michelle Yeboah and John's
elastic cluster see Lauren a green side
almari Raul argh with us
Gotham bahador
Bridget vital on Helicon check or so
Fernando Concha Baumbach Windsor
Cristobal
Rory Kunene ma Jai Mita - Oni Vicky sin
Vultar booze le Dubner Arianna Espinosa
Maria Feliz Kenneth Fujita Ashley
Gottlieb
namwon Jung William Keeler Ryan Kelly
Patrick a penny Emily Kingsley ma petrol
coach in ski Kimberly Cong Jake
Kupperman Dominique Lori peach blur
propun wrote em live quico Hao yuan li
vote Lee Scott liftman Angie Lin
Brittany Carmen Lutz Jordan Marin Maeve
McCoy Christine McLaren James Cole
McWhorter
James many matthew Miller Matias Nadia
Anastasia
Naren Molly O'Connor
[Applause]
Babatunde are going to me and assuming
ootah are da school Charlotte Polson
Eric Perkins
Moses Rana mom say Lucinda Cova Adams
loss guy Shahar Hanna seagull bird
Hayley Smith three sir
Corey stone
alexia tamer
Zachary Thorson JJ's ow
Jinora Villalobos Cavazos Jonathan Yan
Ellen
yang ke yang carry uke
ronzo cluster D begoa or aho Perez Lara
barukh Pedro bharata Lauren Belet Herman
Matias Blomkvist chin my porker
Travis Bowden
Amarinder Chawla
sandy Chang GOG Jean swai Jacob Doyle
Miriam sack crew Gabriel fine gold
Thomas fresh Kent show Fujiwara Raj
Ganguly Cyril gratis how Han Zane Huck
[Applause]
Lewis actor Rubio Lindsey healthman
Timothy her Lexi Hill
Matthew Hoeber Amanda who hang your toe
your togs
[Applause]
pratik Jane Raisa Javed say Moo Myung
harsh Javari Asia Sidney Johnson Michael
Caine show Hey
Casilla Wei Lin lie
Harold's Lee Tim Wu Zhu on land yawns oh
Claire
Lloyd Erin Markovitz
Connor Patrick McKenna
[Applause]
Victor Mauro
Lyndon ray Mouton Tondo and Charlie I
leaned in
Kelvin Eng main new in Lilia no act
Samuel not singer patience Rumi o
Latorre aundrea or on David
Oh scoffs depend Patel
Divya Raj Harry Robertson Jenna shirelle
this one Jamie Schmidt Alexa Schwartz
Jeffrey Silberman Gabriella Stoudamire
Jason sue Chrissy
- now aput Maxwell Tobin Annabelle sigh
jin-hwan Emma
Werner Gillian Windsor ju-on Zheng
cluster II Judith Agarwal
Jarrett Arkin Medina by Cottam OVA there
we go
Eugenio the Carver Ella
Poe a keen barrel Lloyd Blaschka Alison
Bogdanov
Robert Bach Catherine Hilary honor Brown
Isabella capita Neto rag so on cha Dhaka
show Elena day key arrows Nicolas
Drayson Moises Eskenazi mark fab rose
Maria Claudine Fernandez Adam foo
Kyra Ganga Romani Joe grew sake Ananse
Honda and K furred Elena
Hernandez valet Roxanne Hirsch kiya Tana
Hurtado Rodriguez
Antonia Hyman Benjamin James
Elizabeth Kim
Candace Coons Miriam
Rebecca cruel Seth
soon he Jung Kwon Jae min Lee Kamiya
Licari Miranda Sam longer Jill Luqman
Elizabeth McHugh baby and McNally
Charles Mead Chris moon William Morrison
Payton Elizabeth oh man chan pen
[Applause]
Michelle Ainsley Prasad
James Phelan Raymond wah
Dhar PETA Purohit Patricia Riviera's
Daniel Robbins Qi and rouhani Aristotle
to be honest
Timothy silver Jared Smith Joseph summer
Dyke Tim Sten avec Sanford Asher
Sternberg Keith Haven Natalie
sadena Kelly and Tully
[Music]
Arushi Ubu age' Christopher
Waller Justin twice
Christopher Wilhelmy
Liz yay Mandy young Jesse Zunino deed
Sanford Ziegler Victor Zimmerman cluster
F mark Abramowitz I not L dog
Banco Lake Cardoso
Kenneth Chan soo Jeong Chi Mike D'Souza
[Applause]
Stephanie Deutsch Jacqueline huntzinger
Eustace Jonathan fing got Oh Abbie
Freeman Albert Garrido Oh Elaine gang
[Applause]
Jordan G Alonzo when Suslov Guerrero
Matos Samantha kaliba Nicole young bin
Hilaire suck kun Hong we you chick
edward wong
[Applause]
Kristen Volpe Joseph
yo hey and the beautiful Eureka Jia
[Applause]
Anushka Kapoor Jeffrey cats
young-kyu Yoon
Kevin Kline Carrie came Mexico
Michael crabs Lau Jimmy Lee Antonio
lekha Rica I got yours too
Caroline LaVere Tyler Lee Heather Lee
currently Lin sorry Evan Ludwig
an akan met Sebastian mascara duck Hyun
mom Nicholas Nanette II Lauren Amara
sigfredo Rama
Laura Palin tone Alex Palin Tony priyank
pan de terre Pauly
Melissa Pavlovich promote Prasad
you guys ready okay
Mariam Rappaport hinden Charles Rexford
[Applause]
David Schreiber Francisco Sepulveda
Barnett Sarah matcha poles Cyril eart
somebody
Nancy sit - William Smith Michael stack
Emily Steinberg
Alexander Toronto
chayo Taurus
christow she sent us Jillian Wang Ryan
Williams Thomas Williams Vincent Zeus
Lillian
Shia
say yang Denise UHN
[Applause]
class of 2018 we are almost finished
there are two more clusters left just
hold on tight and cheer for the rest of
your classmates to narrow aisle contract
crew Vanel David and SATs
Samuel burger
Rashmi Bhagwat
a beak for Acharya
Maya Brown Joaquin kind of us
Chagall Chopra
Wendy's a wolf rom Nikhil tada
Polina Doherty Adam Escalante Brendan
Fischer
Matthew Fox Minh Rachel Friedman Lauren
Fulton Yvonne Fung Andres Geller Steen
Zachary Gorn Andrew goddess dner Eric
whoa
hey Wu Han Shelly Han Jeff Harrington
Julie hermits Chris playing Jason King
Michael Kahn joy King Michael Katz Adam
urbis name Jessica Jessica Kim Michael
Kerwin
Jason ko Gwang soo Lee Jung Kwang Lee
Emily with Theriot David Lewin Kathryn
Liang Leo way wah Leo young Cory Mahoney
Nicolas Maldonado Leila Maroof Fabrizio
matsing urn
Evan mints Francesca Neptune so -
navantia Charles Ruffini a Poorna remote
Chrisman Michelle Deborah repack
Ryan rip Catherine richer
[Applause]
augusten
ruiz de bois de couleur me say 'no Eric
Sethi
Joseph Stanley Michael Steinberg Matthew
Taylor Slav idea
Kyle fans occur Louis 33 Quang Daniel
Wong
Melissa whoo Sophia and Samora Palacios
cluster H
Alberto Alvarez Fernandez
Oh meet Betty Danielle
it Michael Byerly Carmen Chao
Theresa Chang Kevin Connolly Griffin Dan
Andrew janeck II Elizabeth D XI Sydney
fair
[Music]
Nathaniel Franks
Emily Fukunaga Kevin Jerome
Gilberto jvz Oh Elsbeth grant Alison
brought back
Manu C Gupta
Rob haddock Stephanie who Phillip hum
Jack can't tell us
[Applause]
Raphael King West Alexander Kirschenbaum
and tine Crisco
Nickolas Kramer Jade
Wow Eunice Lee Yuen Li Shu Jing Li
rolling well Aaron marbly Adam Martin
Alexander beber Vitas Jordan McNulty
solo Mendez Maximilian Christopher mole
men Maria Luisa Murad Kevin Nichols
anacott become young Jin
Oh David Osteen
Shawn O'Rourke Varun Pandey
because Patel
or per look Anastasia Pronin Alexander
Richter John Rogers Rohit samarth
[Applause]
Rebecca schmear
Maria
Sebastian you Shimada
Zachary Shuster Jenna stopper Juliet
cicada Carrie table
Stella Wang Kate Whitelaw Bethel Gemma
member on Award winners and on stage
Jenny ray LaRue Victoria din John
Griffin dowdy Imani Gooden
Connor Leary
Andrew quartz Ushio Emily
Snyder Jefferson Taylor Benjamin to be
on uh gem char Kelly Matthew Wilson Anna
all Guinness
Catherine Jane cook Gregory Feldman
Gabrielle Gonzales
TJ ha Bassam who's named Enrique parada
Sarah Chang Kirk Alyn grands Berg
Brunell Mahanta
Kareem Ahmed will meow Jimmy sour beer
Jake
Alcorn Jonathan Dwyer Sheree Lee Sonja
Nanda Homer
Josh land a
Molly Magnussen
ladies and gentlemen graduate number 752
from the class of 2018 kasym muhammad
khaleel peopre ham
okay now I know that I am now in the
unenviable position of standing between
you and your family and friends at a
reception so I'll be brief but I did
want to say just two things the first
and most important is again
congratulations to all of you the second
is a thought and it's this probably as
you were suiting up this morning or last
night and thinking about coming today
somebody mentioned to you that whatever
it was that you had in mind was not the
right thing you should do something else
or those best days are gone I want you
never to believe someone like that and
I'll just leave you with a quick story
some years ago when I was working in the
White House I traveled to Japan to work
on a trade agreement we're still working
on it's called the trans-pacific
partnership it's been a while I came
back with my Japanese colleague and we
landed at Dulles field got in a cab to
go to the capital to talk to some
members of Congress and we passed the
National Archives on which is written
past is prologue talk and Uncas on my
Japanese colleague turned to me and said
what does that mean and I launched into
one of my long-winded college professor
II kind of riffs and the cab driver lost
it and turned around and said what he's
trying to tell you is you ain't seen
nothing yet
that's your future give yourselves
another round of applause
we will this stage will proceed with
graduates behind us if guests could
remain seated while graduates file out
we're going to lead you to Ansel Plaza
across campus where your reception
awaits thank you and God bless once
again ladies and gentlemen please wait
until all the graduates have exited
before exiting the guest seating area
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]